Oh
I think we can get started with the last
talk for today before the panel it's
Giovanni on real-time data-driven
application using Python and pandas
it's kind of harder when they squeeze
you between a talked spying with Python
and German beer but I'll try to do my
best to to make it worth it
my name is Giovanni and zani I am a data
whisper at Garissa driven a small
consultancy firm in the Netherlands and
the talk is about real-time data driven
application using Python and pandas as
beckoned and a bit of info about me
I was born in Italy then I moved to the
Netherlands for laughs
my wife was there okay I did a PhD in
theoretical physics there there I fell
in love with Python and new PI the work
was on DNA mechanics then I went from
for one year KPMG or the one that no
KPMG you can imagine those were my
Python dark months in the sense that I
didn't do any Python and then to
continue with the analogy I had my
Python Renaissance when I went to go to
the driven and this talk is about a
project that we did for one of our
clients by the way you can direct a
snarky feedback live while I talk to my
twitter handle my wife and colleagues
will thank you later and I will give the
email at the end of the talk for even
snarky comments if you don't want them
to be public so what is a what do I mean
by real-time data driven app mostly well
I think almost all apps that we use
every day think about Instagram and what
password manager we store data and we
retrieve it especially with my password
manager I don't expect it to mess with
the data they put there a data driven
app on the other hand could have a
permutation of transform and reach and
analyze phases between when I store the
data and when I retrieve it that is in
my opinion what
makes a data-driven map and real-time is
where at least the retrieve phase is not
is not a batch process I'm speaking
about latency not higher than one to two
seconds for most queries if it's above
that I'd start to go into the batch
realm and an app means something your
mother could use she doesn't need to
understand what she's doing but she
should be able to use it so if she has
to type in some secret code that's
probably not an app my my view so what
is this app about a client of ours in
the Netherlands asked us can we get
insights about the impacts of an event
so the data that they gave us were the
server logs of an application that they
have where people can get online type
the name of an activity or shop of a
restaurant in the Netherlands and get
some basic information like phone number
openings time if available and I said
this is the data that we that we have
try to make something by through which
we can detect if an event has happened
and what was the what was the impact of
this event and the app that we built is
kind of basic we can insert a postal
code the simple in severe ZIP code in
the Netherlands it's composed six
characters four numbers and two letters
then arranged in kilometers so this is
tank kilometers from the center of
Amsterdam and then we can put today
there were a date range this is the day
before Queen's Day last year and Queen's
Day this year for the one well I think
last year was still Queen's Day this
year is Kings day this Dutch day they
always mess around with with vacations
so you put you put the
a day that you want date range and then
you say I want to compare it with a week
before for example assuming that the
week before was a normal week what you
get it's well I cut and paste the UI I
couldn't show the the app that we built
not because they don't trust you but
because they don't trust me so don't
take it personal I do and what you get
its first it's a map in this case of
Amsterdam and when you have when you
have a blue region that means that there
there is an activity that's received
less hits some less people clicked on
that under the activity that is located
there with respect to one week before
when you see some red you see an
activity that has been clicked more with
respect to one week before besides that
you get a timeline this is the time of
this two days in dark blue you see the
hit or the visit for the day before
Queen's Day so you see everybody was
searching where should I drink beer
tomorrow and then Queen's Day self
everybody was drinking beer so nobody
was using the app compared to one week
before which is the light curve which
remain which remains more or less stable
among two days
besides that we get a division by
category we have a top category bars and
restaurant we have many more health
consultancy Fisheries agriculture how
many hits it got and the percentage
variation compared to the previous week
and then we have some categories so each
category has subcategories and you get
the same statistics for for each
subcategory the the very first question
that we always get it is is it big data
is it not just a label that you apply to
yourself to ask for higher consultancy
fees well most of the time it's not but
in this particular case I believe it is
the total log files that he were given
are on the order of 40 terabytes it's a
couple of years of of logs and we use
Hadoop to store and reach and
pre-process the data and for the one
interested we have a ten nodes Hadoop
plus cloud era manager and a a job
tracker test tracker
with about 24 terabytes of storage per
node it's just to give you an idea so
what are the challenges to build such an
app the first one at least in Europe we
just heard it in in the US is not quite
the same it's privacy how can we well
store and process this data while having
privacy taken care of the second is that
it's a huge pile of data if you want to
do some real-time retrieval on top of
real-time retrieval we would also like
to do some real-time analysis because as
we saw we can insert a range in our
application and while this rain changes
what is shown on the table only on the
app is different so when I see the
percentage is percentage changes with
the radius because the amount of
activity that fall within the radius
changes I can also change postcode and
that's the same that's the same story so
privacy for the one of you that work
with privacy before you have to have to
speak with lawyers and Human Resources
and whatnot it can really be a curse but
it's also gifts at least in our case why
is it a gift because you have to trim a
lot of information that either you don't
want to use
you cannot use and you have to group
this information so to get to a certain
level of granularity to be able not to
identify anybody using the app thanks to
privacy what we did was to aggregate all
the hits by the hour so all the eats are
aggregated on an hour level so every
activity as it's a number of hits in in
an hour not on the minute or second and
that brought the data from 40 terabytes
to approximately half terabyte which is
not anymore big data but we didn't
change our fees because of that through
alpha terabyte terabytes still classify
as large data is not big anymore we
didn't do Hadoop after after the
reduction but it's still it can still
offer some some challenges so the third
one was the real-time retrieval which is
kind of harder than it looks because we
have geographical data as I said before
so when you have geographical data and
you put things in a database you don't
have a nice index which is sequential
but you get points on a well on a sphere
or a 2d plane which is way harder to to
retrieve and for the real-time analysis
we just use a golden tail tree through
something like that in the basement now
killing this is the logo of the Python
for data analysis book by Wes McKinney
so we use pandas by Wes McKinney to do
all the real-time analysis and for the
one not familiar with pandas it's a very
powerful library that under the hood
uses new PI and new PI under the hood
uses C so when you if you do things
cleverly with punish you get C light
speed
with your application and that means
that real-time analysis can be done you
see more bodies in a moment so what
about the architecture of this
application so we have a front-end part
some JavaScript written using angularjs
famous JavaScript framework the trance
in the browser this application makes
some rest
HTTP Rascals to a flask Python
application we'll see in a bit or a
flask at is this flask application uses
an helper module to answer the query of
the of the front-end and it gives back
some JSON that then angularjs processes
and it show it to the end-user before
continuing let me tell you that I know
how much Python developers love
JavaScript so I just have two slides in
JavaScript nothing more if you don't
like JavaScript you can just black out
for a moment
so this is the first and the second okay
that was it now to the cool stuff that
is flask
what is flask so flask is the thing that
actually answer to this to the angularjs
making the calls and it's simple yet
very powerful Python framework to use it
it's extremely simple it just imports
flask and then you define an app fruit
which is basically the address that you
put in the address bar and we're telling
this flask application when the user
goes to slash hello just give back a low
word so if I run this application this
is actually working code I can just go
to localhost hello and I'm greeted by
hello world so this is the thing that
well the
served as back-end of course was more
complicated in our case so in this is an
example where we have an API I can give
some arguments so the postal code the
date range and the radius as an optional
argument and what the flask application
will do will call the get JSON function
in the helper module and give us back
some statistics some the time line and
the data point and it will then return
them so let's analyze this get JSON
function oh no before let's see what the
data looks like in this reduce form we
have a column for the day
so for example it is the 8th of January
then we have an hour because everything
is aggregated by hour and have a TV tid
a postal code then they hit it's
received on this particular hour on this
particular day then we have a delta
column that's that are the heat that is
received one week before so you see the
date offset is seven days and then the
SBI is a sector code so in this case SBI
one but then we could have another
activity which has another sector code
so when I say the data and this
application think about something like
this in the database although not
exactly like this so this helper that
that get the JSON looks a bit like this
will we work backwards to see how it
works so at the end it returns what
Agathe before doing that it computes the
statistics and the timeline using data
data is in this case a panda's data
frame that we got in the previous step I
will look at that in a in a minute
the guess statistic function takes this
data data frame then it takes a sector
code and the first thing that it does it
filters the data frame by the settle
code somebody has any question
throughout the code code just raise your
hand or throw something at the stage
afterwards I will sum the hits for that
particular data frame and here I'd like
to point out that when this function get
the data this data it's already filter
by date and by location so we already
have the right data so the data for the
geographical location that we want any
particular days that we want so it gets
all the hits for that look for that
region in that date and it gets the
Delta hit and that is the the hits a
week before at the end of that it
computes a percentage the percentage
change that we saw before and it
displayed this in the user interface so
we see that for this particular sector
code we had two hundred sixty thousand
heads with an increase of 26% with
respect to one week before and it does
so with all the SBI all the codes sector
code and the list is of course longer
then we have the get timeline function
which does but basically does a group by
another group I in our pre-processing we
did a group by date hour and activity
now we don't want to here we don't want
to grouper activity we want to get every
activity in a certain sector so we grew
by date by hour and by and by activity
and then we sum the number of hits and
the Delta hits and the result
something like this so this curve here
that you see is the sum of all the
activities in that region in those days
so D so then here I actually get the
data so now does it work in the first
iteration of the product you kind of
know I'll consultancy work the client is
kind of skeptic about what we can do so
he says ok this is one week this is the
data let's see what what you can do so
in the first iteration we just had three
gigabyte of data instead of half a
terabyte and what I did
don't blame the team I did it myself was
load all the data into a panda's data
frame and put this actually out for the
clients to use the funny so you can see
that we read the source data and then
every time we have to get a certain
subset we just filter its source data
the funny thing is that it actually
worked and it was very fast because
everything is kept in memory and the
advantage of this approach where
everything is a data frame so were you
actually using the data frame a bit like
it will use a database is that it's fast
you use what you know so you don't have
to write ugly secret code in your in
your app you don't have database
administrators we all know we love them
and we all love CSVs just simple files
there are however some disadvantages to
this approach and the first one is that
it doesn't scale beyond memory so when
your data grows big enough pandas cannot
hold it anymore
then you have huge startup time because
every time you start the app it has to
read the whole
CSV file just parse them eventually then
you have no DBAs to point a finger to if
something is wrong with the data and we
all hate CSV sometime because they can
be it also be difficult to to work with
if you want to go down this path set the
data frame index wisely so in our case
we said the index of the data frame in
the initial iteration to be an index by
date and then we aligned the data to the
index so that date first of January work
continues with date in the second of
January because in how you use their app
and you query the data you're always
squaring contiguous days and this speeds
up the query system in imbalance by a
factor of ten or something if you have a
lot of lots of data and if you go down
this path
beware of modification of the original
data frame you don't want to have
function that modifies the data that you
loaded so always be careful with that
you also get some nice things so for
example joins in data frame are super
fast and why are they fast
well as you see I took a screenshot when
I was up voting this answer and the
answer is that West McKinney is genius
and therefore he wrote
and therefore wrote a very smart
algorithm to do merges in in pandas
dataframe as I said before should enjoy
this moment of glory right made you all
laugh as I said before you don't have to
go down this path and in that case what
we did we adds an additional module a
database module where we put all all
database codes there the database would
then well the database module would then
interface with Postgres post-crash
through the up cycle PG to package and
in the helper module all we did was to
change the api from this to this
so we added the database connection
string and that was it so we can from
here upwards we didn't have to change
anything basically now handling
geographical data what we what did we do
so when you enter a postcode you want to
know a zip code you want to know which
zip code fall within the given radius
from that Center zip code so in the
Netherlands we have approximately
400,000 zip code it's a small country
but they like to categorize everything
so every three numbers in the street you
get a new zip code and it truly is true
it's a and in Italy we get 50,000 people
perceive code and in the Netherlands
maybe 15 so just to give you an idea
when you want to do such a kind of
filter in pure Python so you want to
basically use the heavy sign distance
which is the distance which is the
formula the equation to get a distance
between two points even latitude and
longitude in pure Python
filtering 400,000 postcodes using that
function takes three comma five seconds
or something like that my MacBook Pro
these already puts the app outside the
real time category of that app that I
spoke about before so what we used here
was again numpy so we did well just
leverage new by a vectorized operation
Anoop i can do the same query 160 times
faster than pure python it's a huge huge
speed up however when you do such a
query and given that the Netherlands has
so many so many host codes if you has
for the postcode within a 10-kilometer
read radius of Amsterdam
you get some 10,000 postcodes back
postal codes that means that the stick
of the C tool that you have to write a
select star from data point or select
something from data point where the
postcode should be into this giant array
of 10000 element so I don't know if this
well we try with both my CTO and
Postgres and the point is that the
execution engine has to parse this is
huge
query here and just to do that it takes
a couple of minutes and he needs to
fetch the data and we would see queries
that would run for 20 minutes just to
get the data back it was clearly
unacceptable so what we try to do first
they may be familiar with Portuguese
Portuguese is a possible extension to
handle geographical data so it allows
you to do queries like this select
everything from the data point where the
position is within 1500 meters of the
reference latitude and
longitude it's the API it's very clean
it's not very well-documented politician
and in general but to do this query it's
very clean you don't have to do fussy
things but there's a catch with half a
terabyte of data the index the
geographical index that you need to put
on latitude and longitude as half a
terabyte so the data is off a terabyte
the index at least when you have
latitude and longitude to the seventh
digit after the comma is another half a
terabyte that means that just to build
the index you need a week three four
days it's really really long the other
thing is that queries are very slow once
the radio starts to grow it has
something to do with memory if the index
is too large for memory Cosgrove's try
to do other clever things which don't
end don't end up to be very clever
because we had to discard this method at
the end of the day but if you have less
data postage is a great addition to
portress so we had to find other
solutions so being very familiar with a
dupe we tried a different explored other
options the first is Apache HBase BD
Hadoop database but if you know a bit
about HBase it also works with
sequential index illnesses and some
index on plane or on a sphere does not
work for the way HBase is its structured
Impala I don't know how many of you know
Impala yeah one two three okay good job
Clara Impala is a database that
developed by a cloud era which runs on
top of it now
it's a query CQ query engine which runs
on top of Hadoop and runs in memory so
it should be very very fast but it's not
faster than Postgres when you have just
half a terabyte of data it you really
see clip Impala shines when you do
queries with a 3 4 10 20 terabytes of
data then another candidate its MongoDB
you know MongoDB is also native support
for geographical data but what once we
tuned the porous database as I show in
the next slide
MongoDB turned out not to be so fast as
as they advertised so another story we
stayed with that with Postgres and we
need the following step the first one is
to align the data on disk by date so
once again the date is our primary index
in the table and if you align the data
by date well basically what the database
does it does sequential reads on the
disk instead of doing random reads to
get things that happen on the same day
this happened through the cluster
keyword in Postgres I suppose not many
people know it because they chose
probably the worst keyword ever to
indicate that you want to align data on
disk but it's very powerful this alone
sped up our queries by I think more than
an order of magnitude the second trick
is to use a temporary table to get the
postcode the postal codes that we wanted
so I told you before that when you put a
10,000 items array in the query the
database execution engine kind of flips
out but if you put all the sports codes
into a temporary table is extremely fast
to put them there and then to filter
your data point you just do a join with
this temporary table
in this way the database engine doesn't
have to parse all this 10,000 postcode
but it just reads from the table it's
way more efficient
this also sped up things by three or
four X so it's apt a lot but ultimately
what we did was to lose some precision
on the postal code so if we go from six
character postal codes to four character
postal codes we actually go from 400,000
postal codes to 10,000 maximum and at
the end of the day one two and three
brought the queries from 20 minutes to
maximum five or six seconds and for very
large ready and for every day used to
milliseconds I to number four it's it's
kind of between bracket because it's a
no-brainer when you work with these kind
of things always compress the data
flowing from the database to the
application the flask application and
from the flask application to the
front-end also compress the data because
you especially when it begins to be big
bigger so if you're trying to bring 40
megabytes from the flask application to
an iPad or something it will probably
need minutes on a mobile connection and
if you if you compress it instead of 40
megabytes you get three or four
megabytes way more manageable and that
was it
as everybody else we're hiring we're in
the Netherlands where everybody speak
English and we use a metric system so if
you like English and the metric system
it's a great place to live and as
promised this is my email and I will put
the slides online somewhere today
so you have any question
there's one in the front
thank you for a toast
can you go to the previous slide with
the table yes this one but if you have
concurrent operations how can you create
everytime a table with the same name is
that the lock
every time you the app receives we
actually append a random number after
the name of the table and it's a
temporary table so every time we close
the database connection it it gets
deleted and it lives in memory okay so
it's now I'm showing you role CQ but
actually the secret is call from a
Python function inside the database
module inside that function we we do
every time a random number between 1 and
million or something we create a table
in a random name would pass that random
name to the following query and then we
close the database connection and the
table is down
how I understood it you have this
restful api and then you receive a call
and then you do the computations and
then you return the the answer right
isn't that a bit risky in general I mean
you cannot really make sure that the
computations always finish and if they
don't finish you might really end up
with no reply at all or you might also
risk may be that people are just
blocking your computing machines if you
just receive I don't know 100 requests
which which take real long well we don't
have many concurrent user as of now and
I think for the first question you
probably want something that where is it
it's in one of these two slides
I mean JavaScript does some essing thing
so what we see that the user interface
is waiting for data to comes in and the
various part of the user interface that
is this are being displayed are as the
data comes in I mean this is just one
two and three the data comes with the
same request so they all are visualized
at the same time but we actually have
more requests that that do some
instagrams and other things with the
data that come in later sooner or later
so it's some asynch stuff and as you may
have inferred um no JavaScript expert
but it all seems to work for concurrency
I agree but I think we had five to ten
concurrent users and database machine
and the web server just kept going
without any without any issues
more JavaScript consider it using SSD
for the database to speed up data
collection come again
have you have you consider it I use an
SSD disk for the database back-end no we
had the idea to do that however we are
in the innovation part of this
innovation side of this client and
somehow getting SSD disk is not
innovative enough so we either attitude
to pay bye-bye but we definitely think
about it and the point is that when you
have half a terabyte of database you're
on the limit what SSD can do and it's
not very scalable at sample at some
point and once we did this once we did
this the client was so happy that is
enough for us but especially for for the
postcode retrieval
so here the date are continues but the
postcode are not continues because well
they behave a bit like geographical data
so an SSD would greet greatly help the
speed of the of the application because
then it's the random read random reads
are basically almost free so yes we
definitely thought about that but didn't
get the money more questions
why not use WebSocket to stream data to
the application come again why not use
the WebSocket technology of html5 to
stream data to the application instead
of an RX API from the database you mean
oh I don't know I just import psycho PG
and did whatever defaulted and so we
just connect through some default port
I think well the default port host port
and I let the the library handle it all
so it's I wouldn't know the well the
underlying details of the connection I
had to say that for the first phase we
did it the DD web app and the database
were on the same machine so we just said
to the 2d to the app it's a connection
to local house on this port and we just
let the DD the psycho PG do all the rest
okay in case there are no more questions
let's thank you running again
and of course you're all invited to join
the pan and I'll see you over there
you